so a lot of things have happened to you
over the past few months your your star
has risen last you were here you had a
blue twitter verification check you do
not have it anymore you are as far as I
know the only public person to have
their blue verification check for those
that don't know what it means I mean it
basically means you are who you are so
that your celebrity or your identity
yeah it's just saying you are who you
are that's it right
but you had yours removed I don't think
there's been any other case of that
happening and it clearly was a punitive
measure so just real quick though the
shore I just want people under 10 we're
not doing this to be so inside Road my
little Twitter account got whatever it
matters because Twitter is using using a
mechanism to protect public figures like
us from impersonation and also they're
privileged concerns when somebody's
speaking to me in my role as a
journalist they have an expectation of
privacy and have legal privilege yeah
now people are DMing people with my name
on Twitter giving personal information
about their lives oh that exposes
Twitter to liability too by the way
there's very seriously you know there's
a reason why it's a good idea to have
public figures verify but they used it
as an ideological weapon and now when I
went to the White House to ask about
this Josh earnest to others and he said
very interestingly I thought the
president would be the first to affirm
that the success of these social
networking companies rests on their
commitment to First Amendment principles
now he wasn't saying you can enforce the
First Amendment private companies right
I mean I get thrown out of the
conservative Club if I've tried to write
to suggest that and just to be clear the
First Amendment is about the government
taking away your free speech yes it's
not people taking away but the late
Aaron Schwartz the founder of Reddit
said you know censorship has a meaning
outside the government when private
companies have a monopoly on certain
kinds of speech now Twitter certainly
does not only because it has such a
stranglehold on journalism and the media
but also because invented an entirely
new public square if you're in a park
and you make a joke that is involves
race or say or sex or whatever and the
publican doesn't like it you can go to
another pub down the road there is no
other Twitter all right this is a
fundamentally important part of our
media and our democracy so they're
controlling basically one of the big
highways that
for me right and it come there comes
with responsibilities it comes
responsibility Oh users do one of two
things one be honest and sage know what
we're a liberal space pure conservatives
sooner or later you're gonna get banned
we don't really want you here but you
can stay for as long as you know you
don't piss us off too much and I piss
them off too much and they have banned
people not you always in one direction
you were banned also I guess suspended
now and again because I make jokes about
feminists feminists or whatever so what
I said that I I said that I'd been
appointed social justice editor of
BuzzFeed right um as a joke oversee a
lot of people took you seriously yeah
which was the point it was funny idiots
you know idiots and then I and then
immediately after that when people were
tweeting Ben Smith the boss and say how
dare you hire this man I'm never eating
buzz feed again when I knew that it had
taken hold
then I started the hashtag feminism is
cancer man I did it polls you know would
you rather your children had feminism or
cancer and 22,000 people voted and they
voted for cancer and I had the cancer
survivors emailing me saying I'm a
two-time cancer survivor and I still
chose cancer funny anything like that
very much so yes the point is if you are
these days irreverent mischievous
provocative and to do those things you
have to be conservative because the
establishment is it's not just liberal
but but progressive liberal if you want
to be punked these days you want to be
cool and dissident and mischievous you
have to be conservative and if you are
that on Twitter so you're not late
you're gonna lose your account now they
should be honest about that or they
should have they should enforce free
speech and not this weird there's a
weird definition of free speech that
Jack Dorsey seems to have the the the
CEO of Twitter yeah he seems to think
that it's a sort of freedom from rather
than freedom to so free speech on
Twitter means freedom from conservatives
freedom from different points of view
and it plays into the safe space and
trigger warning culture that I know that
you and your listeners know know more
than enough about already it's freedom
from ever having to be exposed to
anything that might make you feel
uncomfortable
well that's not what freedom of speeches
and Forrest he needs to stop lying to
users that Twitter is you know the free
speech we have the free speech party
it's very clear if you step off you feed
off reservation on most of these social
networks you're going to be punished and
and Facebook too by the way
you know teaming up with Angela Merkel
in Germany I think everybody knows this
now yeah
to sense a perfectly reasonable
mainstream discussion from citizens who
are concerned about mass immigration
into their country about millions of
people coming into their country about
the rape epidemics about all sorts of
awful things that are happening to young
German girls Facebook won't let you talk
about it you know just to prove that
this is true and that you're not making
this up I've had two hundred make six
months yeah but I have I have two
instances where I have a decent
connection at Facebook oh and I've had
two instances one where my former guests
Faisal Syed Ali Matar who's been here
twice who is from Iraq a refugee from
Iraq who is now living in the West and
fight through was around his page got
banned because people didn't like that
he was speaking out against the Islamism
and then I had a group of atheist
Muslims that their page got banned as if
it was hate speech so what you're saying
I'm just given I just want people to
understand real you're not just they do
it to everybody and they'd and they
don't even care now about violating
their own sacred tenets you know this
identitarian you know nonsense where
you're serving a protected class from
you know as far as liberals are
concerned if you're a woman or if you're
gay if you're black whatever you know
now there are universities that there
are university students who are no
platforming black transsexuals because
you know they get invited by Jews this
stuff has become in generally happened
last week and they don't mind they don't
mind if you're gay or if you're brown
skinned or whatever what they what they
will not tolerate is diversity of
opinion you know the diversity of skin
color has gone out the window now if you
want to cry victim if you want to
pretend you're an oppressed class you'll
get all sorts of plaudits from the left
you'll get all sorts of rewards they
don't care so much about that however
what they really don't want what they
are terrified of because they can't
fight it with facts is libertarian
conservative points of view and that
freedom from ever being challenged on
anything that freedom from ever having
to encounter something with which you
might disagree or something that might
make you feel uncomfortable or something
that might ridicule you is the
definition of freedom has taken hold on
the left in America today and it is
poisonous it is you know it is entirely
antithetical to democracy to the free
and open exchange of ideas to classical
liberalism to intellectual inquiry so
that's what it is though really that
classical liberalism has really been
pushed aside
that's where I lives in anymore that
nobody really understands nobody even
knows that it exists I think what's on
the universities I speak at I mean you
know I'm on my tour at the moment of
universities and the thing that has
amazed me is the extent to which the
faculties at these universities don't
just refuse to expose their students to
different points of view
they don't just ridicule conservative
points of view they don't even know
about them you know that it's been for a
while fairly well known that the number
one textbook economics textbook in this
country in America you know on set lists
is Karl Marx right say what you want
about it's kind of a conservative
talking point but it's becoming
increasingly clear especially at liberal
arts colleges that don't have any sort
of federal regulations about you know
what the sorts of thing that the
government doesn't get involved in what
they teach and these liberal arts
colleges the professor's don't even know
alternative points of view let alone
teach their students when I go to these
colleges and I did you know I suggest
that perhaps you don't have to give 75
percent of your earnings away to the
government for them spend it on feminist
dance therapy perhaps you know you know
perhaps this wage gap stuff isn't real
after all I mean some of the students
look at me weird like slack-jawed horror
shock surprise it's like it's it's like
a revelation to them the fact that
somebody might come and actually ask for
evidence-based policy and evidence-based
beliefs rather than this sort of bizarre
ideology that they're being fed at the
moment which is only really flourishing
because of the safe space culture and
the trigger morning culture because it
can never be interrogated because it can
never be challenged because it can never
be it can nope nobody is allowed to say
well what about this you know you you're
suggesting that women get paper or what
about this like say this by you by Milo
showing up to a college and saying a
couple things you're not I've never
heard you incite violence right I've
never heard you call to to hurt anyone
directly you're saying things you're
even admitting I mean I think it's clear
that you're admitting that you do
sometimes go over the line of what you
even think is proper sort of to just
elicit a response from politics and it
isn't true but I'll certainly use
provocative language I mean I don't you
know I'll go up and I mean back
jokes and I'll do all that kind of stuff
because you know it's we're still
allowed to make jokes in this guy
because it's fun yeah well no well you
say that but now we're let's say that
but Chris Rock sign for all these
comedians comedian and you understand
this go
you know comedians like gay people we
spoke about this in the last the last
time I was here so Canaries in the coal
mine with this stuff they understand the
threats to creative freedom before
everybody else and no you can't make
jokes in this country anymore you can't
make this joke you cannot make innocent
jokes in this country anymore without
running serious risk of professional
professional damage and social censure
and if you are a public figure making a
joke about anything to do with race or
gender or anything you know you are at
risk you're at risk from one of these
one of these mobs coming offs you you
know it's so funny because I'm obviously
as big of a free speech proponent as
could possibly exist and I think
sometimes that I'm tweeting something
and I'm thinking man if someone looks
back on this in ten years if this
ideology if this left this ideology
keeps taking sinning worse I'm gonna
drown in jail in ten years they're gonna
go oh because there'll be a law passed
and said well 10 years ago you tweeted
that this and that but but well I prefer
to take a more courageous approach to it
and I you know the the proper response
to our to our rage culture is to be
outrageous right I prefer to double-down
if somebody says that they find
something offensive I will tell a joke
twice as bad yeah because words don't
hurt you certainly show being British in
gay I think gives a certain leash that
was I think it's my it's my my hard work
and in fact based you know argument
reason recognize it's probably got more
to do with my good looks look at the
hair am i it's the hair no but you you
do get a certain leash because of your
persona now you've built that yourself
so I don't mean that to discredit you in
any way and I know how hard you built is
a misleading word I've always been this
ridiculous make you see I feel that the
regressives made me like this you feel
you were born this I was born ridiculous
you know I was born we're forcing
ridiculousness upon you because you have
to make a point to the crazy people that
you have to try to live with right so
alright let's back up a little bit cuz I
want to talk a little bit more about the
social media companies themselves so
you've made a good point about Twitter I
mean there's no doubt that Twitter we
know that their shadow banning right
whereas people were popular people who
say unpopular things suddenly just don't
show up
about people wondered about this for a
while and I was the one that brought the
story because I had confirmation from
multiple people that they work with very
closely saying that and Twitter admitted
yes we absolutely do do this we
whitelist certain accounts so they show
up in the top of search results and we
blacklist some accounts so they dumped
and you know this is not in question
it's not a it's not a conspiracy theory
many things on Twitter
feel a bit like conspiracy yeah Oh
they've banned another hashtag and
sometimes I think might have done and
sometimes they definitely didn't know
I'm pretty sure they're fiddling around
with the regressive left they are
fertile yeah there's no question
whatsoever because they have admitted
just to sources that have come to us
that we've we've published as a result
you know they've admitted that they
actively manipulate their network in
order to favor people they like and
officers their business partners but
it's also people that they like
ideologically so that really is 1984
kind of stuff for what we can have in
2016 this type of manipulative ever
talking perfectly and talk to do it yeah
they just stop lying about it right
that's perfect I'll to do if they want
to run their network like that fine the
business will collapse the Conservatives
are all leave and most liberals actually
also want to win on the merits they
don't want to they don't want the game
to be rigged right there I mean I like
to think most liberals a nice decent
honest people who would like to win on
the merits and I think most I haven't
seen much evidence of that in the last
time well it's only those we would in
hijacked I really am affirm I mean I see
what's happening haven't been hijacked
you see that I have so many friends like
this and you're all idiots it's very
clear yeah movin has left you behind
there's no space no space for free
speech on the left and not just this bit
of the left most of the left you are in
a tiny slice on the left of people who
still care about reason rigor fact
scrutiny and free speech and there is no
place for you on the left anymore so you
need to come over and you need to just
just just give in we're gonna do the
cell job today believes in free speech
thing is good marketing but give it up
this seriously because there's nothing
for you on the left anymore
well they don't even like you yeah they
don't like you they decided now that if
you're gay but you're white and a man
the white man bits of the privilege from
the gay bit and then and now they're
telling us that our
now they're telling us that our sexual
preference is a racist like if you've
gotten your Grindr profile I could
prefer white guys and I wrote a column
on this it says the only joke that I
ever had censored my employers are
wonderful so supportive and brilliant
they let me write that everything I want
is the one that they said you want to do
that I said what my Grindr profile says
blacks only is that racist although of
course I wouldn't put blacks only
because that might put some people off
I'll do words that create the same
effect you know like don't contact me if
you're under seven inches and you know
your dad is there now policing our
sexuality you know and they're saying
like you know that you straight white
gay men well well it's the straight
white bit that's the problem so that
sorry the white gay men and you so
that's sort of what I see with the
problem with this ideology come on I
know you're gonna work this in the next
hour you're gonna be working but what I
see the problem is is that there's never
an end to it so they they sort of used
days to get a little more power and now
they're done with well you've now that's
what you're saying realize that what we
discussed in our last show completely
wrong and I was completely right when I
said that you were part of the problem
that you had bought out into this sort
of domestication of homosexuals the
Liberals just want to pluck you down in
gay areas though where do you live you
live that gay area don't you okay yeah
of course you do you know plunk you down
with your dog and your husband and you
know you're nice like nice domestic life
and now they've got you now they've got
you you'll be a Democrat voter forever
you know it's easy like they can move on
to the next group and they just got you
in the bag and the whole point we talked
about last time about sort of dissident
gay culture but the most exciting people
being the free thinkers I think you're
now starting to realize I was right
which is lovely very quite funny for me
wonderful oh I realize that the left
yeah well look I realized without
question that the left has lost its mind
as to the point that it's a slice like
this I do think that the fight that my
side of this on the left is starting to
wake up in big numbers so I don't think
we all have to somehow defect to you
guys just yet as much as you'd like say
you guys I mean I'm not a Republican I
mean I'm I'm British for stop I won't
even vote here I mean I'm a daddy
supporter but yeah we're gonna get to
Daddy Cool's from that called Trump
daddy everybody knows this now so just
wrapping up the the social media stuff
and free speech related to these
companies if these company
are run by these social justice warriors
and it really does seem like look I
don't want to lose my Twitter
verification so I don't get they're
gonna ban you great please don't lose it
you're gonna go so look I don't want to
lose that and I and I don't want to be
banned on Facebook and I you know we put
our videos up on YouTube obviously I saw
last week or two weeks ago there was
this organization that does translations
from Arabic and they all they do is
translate what Imams are saying in
mosques yes at least telling about
killing all the Jews and they got banned
for hate speech all they do is translate
the hate speech enough those don't way
you should know what the Muslims are
saying they don't want you to know
what's happening in these mosques
because if people knew about it they
might be less happy with this you know
this huge influx of immigration they
might be less happy about having their
own perfectly reasonable points of view
censored and mischaracterized is hate
speech means is what the left does it
mischaracterizes ridicule and criticisms
abuse and harassment
it came mischaracterizes perfectly valid
ordinary anxieties regular people are
justified in having yeah as hate speech
I'm looking out on the world now and I'm
thinking people like Tommy Robinson from
the EDL he's been on the show right and
I'm thinking there were some things he
said in the 90s and whatever it was you
know okay find too much and the violence
is obviously obviously unacceptable but
I'm listening to him now and people are
all Tommy Robinson's racist bigoted I
mean I can't find anything to disagree
with I can't find anything to disagree
with it in the speech when he went to
Oxford University who mapped out his his
life and what he how he saw his
community changing and how he saw the
police either hamstrung are actively
lying about it the government lying
about or the media lying about it all
this stuff is now playing out social
media and the scary thing about these
companies is that they are totally
totally they are in lockstep with
government Facebook Germany lockstep
yeah with with Merkel yeah their video
of soccer Berg you know Twitter here
lockstate they have meetings at all day
every day with this week you know with
with the government officials at
lockstep on this stuff I don't know what
they're gonna do when when daddy goes
into the White House but but no it's
terrible I should tell people when you
say daddy you're talking Trump just for
the people that don't know or lingo
everybody yes yet
Varenka Trump will get to forum
referring to the goddamn to Trump it is
the goddamn for an incoming Trump and
right so I've realized if I accomplish
nothing else with you while sitting here
I want you we've accomplished nothing so
nothing happens over but I want you to
at least make this the different
distinction between when you talk about
the left and leftist versus liberals
want to make that distinction so you
just think I'm just the outlier of this
situation but yeah 50 million viewers
then whatever the hell numbers they have
this so if so most people don't come
from nowhere that's what the left is
that's the that's the long there
anything I wouldn't call those people
liberal work of linguistic history that
the American Left is it's called the
liberal movement because they don't
believe in liberalism they're not
classical liberals but I'm sorry you
know arguing over words like the left
likes to do isn't that going to change
the fact that the entire left side of
the American political spectrum has gone
mad and if you you know you just can't
in good conscience vote Democrat if you
you know if you don't believe in any of
this stuff if you want us to be able to
have discussions like this not just on
your show but on the national news and
in the pages of the newspapers if you
believe in that you cannot vote Democrat
well that's where these [ __ ]
have caught me they've really pushed me
into a corner here because everything
all all the free speech stuff right you
know fighting against ideology
secularism all of that stuff that's
right that's my stuff that's the stuff I
really care about and praising the left
is so the left right now is crazy on the
stuff I care about most and I say that
as someone that is never not voted
Democratic ever and here we are